make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin all right what's going on
guys this
is rob and we are picking back up again
with batman again we're kind of
continuing the aftermath of joker war
but this time
we are picking up with batman's new
villain the ghost maker and this guy's
cool
and i dig what's happening here here's
the funny thing is i didn't expect like
ghost maker to encounter batman for like
another three issues or so
right off the bat like you have you you
like literally in this first issue
batman takes this guy on and it's kind
of crazy right it's kind of wonky here
so um because of the fact that this is
kind of the aftermath of joker war we're
still going to see some themes
from that story being thrown in but the
first thing we do here is we get this
bit of an exposition right in downtown
gotham city really in an old town uh
you've got basically ghost
ghost maker talking to this cop and this
cop's been captured this guy's been
strung up and ghost maker's kind of
giving us this perspective of gotham
city right in the sense that he hates
gotham city but here's the funny thing
about this is it's not this typical like
i hate gotham city it's one of these
things where he's kind of like
this city is not going to improve more
so than that he goes as far as to say
that he realized pretty early on that he
was not going to improve here and so the
first bit of indication we get in terms
of the story of ghost maker is that he
seems to originate from gotham city and
then ultimately he ended up leaving the
place
that from his perspective the city
smells of like urine and blood and and
violence and death
is just a really crappy place to be but
the funny thing about this
is that in in his mind he kind of says
like this city should be burned to the
ground
but instead of taking this almost kind
of like dark knight rises approach where
it's like i'm gonna poison people's
souls all that kind of stuff
instead his idea is if i had all the
billions of the world like bruce wayne
does i would relocate all of you
burn the city to the ground and then let
you rebuild it into something better
that's actually not a bad approach
it's violent but it's basically taking
the city as it's so twisted and screwed
up
tearing it all down and then letting the
people build it up into something better
so it's not wholly like a villainous
approach there's actually some good
there and that's one of the things that
struck me right off the bat in terms of
the nature of this guy he's not a
wholesale villain right he's not a
straight up bad guy and so what this guy
basically says is this cop is kind of
strung up you know he's like he's like
you know what is it that you want right
like why are you saying all this and the
response of ghost maker is my ghost net
right so basically his technology has
made its way into the computer systems
of gotham and he knows every single
crime that's going on and he's like i'm
going to solve
all of them for you but what you're
going to do to me in return is you're
going to give me the location of clown
hunter you're gonna tell me how to find
this clown hunter kid and it's kind of a
crazy thing because this cop's like
we're not dirty right i'm like i'm not a
dirty cop i'm not just gonna give you
information right you you bad guys don't
work that way and so he's like i'm not
batman right like i'm the ghost maker
i'm better than batman and i'm here to
prove that i am right now from there it
switches over to what is effectively
a new concept in dc comics well i guess
new
is a bit of a misnomer we pick up with a
group called the grinners the reason why
i say this is kind of new but kind of
not back in the 1940s back
back when it was uh timely comics before
it became atlas comics and then
eventually marvel comics you had a line
of comics that were called
mystery comics uh you had a a line of
comics called mystery comics which are
exactly what they sounded like right
this was before
marvel became the superhero publishing
house that we know it to be now right
before spider-man the fantastic four
they published mystery stories right
sometimes there were ghost stories
sometimes it was science fiction but
the idea here is that back then what you
had is in mystery comics number seven
you had a creator named dr weems and dr
williams was a guy who was trying to
find a kind of cure for pneumonia and it
was really more of marvel's attempt to
kind of build on the superman mythos
insofar as superman was a champion of
the people he fought against like
government censorship and against like
crony politicians and bad bad business
guys and stuff like that right so the
result of this is that in
in mystery comics number seven dr weems
was created by al gabriel as a guy who
wanted to find a cure for pneumonia
believed he'd found it experimented on
himself and then basically ended up
becoming
uh what was called the grinner and this
was a guy who had like this really
sadistic grin on his face it's a pretty
cool concept right but the idea here is
that the grinners have actually been
around in gotham city for a long
long time right during the days of like
harley quinn the idea here though is
that the grinners are not your typical
joker henchmen your typical joker
henchmen are guys who are like criminals
or down on their luck or they're in some
weird situation and it's just easy money
right i mean it's a risk working for the
joker these are basically guys who are
like the most hardcore
that whenever the joker implements these
great big huge grandiose schemes they're
some of the first people to act but it's
more of a desire to prove themselves to
the joker than it is
actually you know being joker henchmen
per se now for the most part the joker
doesn't really seem to mind their
actions because what they do falls part
and parcel with this plan but these are
the most die-hard of the die-hard right
these are the most extreme guys and
whenever the joker isn't really doing
anything whenever he doesn't really have
a major plan
they're basically lying low and that's
kind of what's been going on here is
these guys are effectively lying low now
this information is given to batman by
virtue of oracle
barbara gordon and one of the things
tinyon does is he says like right off
the bat she's not gonna stay in this
role full time uh she's gonna be
bouncing back and forth between oracle
and batgirl now for those of you guys
who are not familiar with the batman
mythos if you are familiar with this
bear with me for the next minute or two
for those of you guys who are not
familiar with this in the aftermath of
the killing joke with barbara gordon
being shot and paralyzed and no longer
being allowed to to operate as
as batgirl this all kind of tied into
the events of like crisis on infinite
earth right so kind of distilling the
batman mythos down to a more singular
story that focus on batman himself and
so for her part barbara gordon was
really sort of consolidated down
and simply just became an information
broker now this went from the 80s into
the 90s and then eventually she returned
back to being batgirl again but there
are a lot of people who look at the
character of oracle
and see her as probably the best version
of barbara gordon because she played a
far more prominent role in dc comics
than she did as batgirl uh basically the
information that's given to batman
is this is one of the safe houses of the
uh of the the grinners and that for the
most part
nothing really seems to be going on here
right there there's some that are
playing pool there's some that are
chilling at the bar that are playing
cards just kind of staying low-key
until things pop off but the other thing
about this is that this is about the
clown hunter kid you guys remember him
from uh joker war he was this kid that
had enough the joker doing all the stuff
that he was doing and looking at batman
and seeing him as a guy who was only
really ever a half measure right like
well you know we got to keep them alive
even though we know they're going to
kill people we can't kill the villains
because we don't kill and so the results
of that is a clown hunter stepped up and
said okay if batman's not gonna kill
villains then i will and so he basically
went on this campaign
and started killing all the clowns of
the joker everywhere he found them and
so what batman's looking to do here is
cut this kid off
and basically say okay like i'm gonna
round these guys up and take him to jail
before the kid can kill them right the
problem is as soon as he gets in there
they're already dead and they weren't
killed by clown hunter all these guys
are
already dead right and the reason why
barbara gordon saw them playing pool or
playing cards is because the
video footage that she saw was on a
constant loop this all just one great
big huge trap
this specifically is more of a message
and batman sees a kind of face
graffitied on the wall and then
immediately tells barbara gordon
deactivate your computer systems right
shut it all down maintain radio silence
i'll let you know what's going on when
this is all over right so batman just
immediately cuts her off you know and
that's when he tells her like this is
the personal thing and so from here
we jump back to what's basically
explained as many years ago what we end
up doing is picking up in dublin and we
have this guy
named tommy it's either tommy tuvane or
tommy tavani um i would say tommy tavani
if he was italian but the guy looks like
he's irish right so tommy to vayne it
really you know
whatever the case is i mean the guy's
you know i assume he's irish because you
know he's
in ireland uh but um this guy you know
for those of you guys across the pond
who are more familiar like whether
you're in britain or whether you're
actually in ireland proper you guys
could probably answer this question
better than i could is it actually tommy
tavani or tommy tevane but you end up
having bruce wayne showing up here and
literally throwing this guy out the
window now it's not because of the fact
that bruce wayne's got a bone to pick is
because bruce wayne wants tommy to train
him right he's like i'm trying to get
your attention you wouldn't listen to me
in the bar
so now i have your full attention you're
going to teach me everything you know
you're the best knife wielder in the
world you're the best at using knives
and knowing how to throw them at people
how to utilize them so
like you're gonna you're gonna teach me
and i'm gonna show you that i'm a worthy
people right i'm gonna beat the crap out
of you and you're gonna show me that
you're then i'm gonna show you i'm worth
a damn and you're gonna teach me right
the problem with this is that
you end up having a guy who seemingly
comes out of nowhere now bruce wayne
recognizes this kid and of course given
the circumstance
this is basically ghost maker when he
was younger right i mean given the
nature of the comic but like batman
you know bruce wayne is kind of like
okay like i recognize this kid which
indicates that bruce wayne knew who he
was they knew each other in gotham city
and he basically says
like i'm the new student right like i'm
the new student like like you bruce
wayne like you're just a rich kid right
who's still crying over the fact that
his mommy and daddy died like that's all
you really are see that's why i say
in batman begins the best description of
bruce wayne right the best
the best definition of bruce wayne came
when he went to go meet uh carmine
falcone i think is who it was who was
played by tom wilkinson and like he goes
into the bar and he goes in there with a
handgun like he's gonna shoot him
and they literally sit him down they
took his gun away and tom wilkinson's
talking to him you know and he's like
he's like he's like you're you're bruce
wayne right you're the the prince of
gotham you'd have to go a thousand miles
to find someone who doesn't know your
name right like you've never tasted
desperate you never know what it meant
to struggle right you think because your
mommy and daddy got
shot that you really understand what the
darker nature of the world is like like
you don't understand this world you're
just like a rich kid who lost his mom
and dad you don't know the first thing
about this criminal underworld but it's
one of these things where like ghost
maker really seems to kind of reiterate
this message you're going on a crusade
you want to come become some great big
huge superhero who can take on criminals
because you feel like you really
understand the criminal element because
a criminal shot your mom and dad no no
i'm a person who really understands
the base level of the world now again we
don't really know much about
ghost maker we don't know if he's
somebody like like thomas elliot right
or if he's somebody who literally is
just from like the worst part of gotham
and somehow knew bruce wayne in their
past but is like lived in in just
the struggle and strife that comes with
being in gotham city right just the
lowest of the low right living down in
the the lower caste the lower
class of society in the worst way but
what you end up getting is basically
these two guys who are essentially
fighting each other
right like this this guy you know ghost
maker says look if you want him to train
you you're gonna have to go through me
because i'm already a student so
let's get this on and when they get into
an initial scuffle right off the bat
bruce wayne is completely outclassed
and that's kind of the crazy thing here
is it's like he's literally like you're
still
too slow right you're still not fast
enough to keep up with me and so it
really seems to lend credence to the
idea
that ghost maker really is just a better
fighter than bruce wayne
across the board that's kind of the the
crazy thing here so what we end up doing
is switching back to the modern day by
switching back to the present day you've
got harley quinn meeting with a landlord
right and she's like i want to rent this
apartment and he's like
no you're not a reasonable human being
like you're harley quinn uh you bring
nothing but problems and she's like look
i'll pay you double rent right like
i'll pay you twice the rent that you
normally make and then we'll be cool
right now of course this guy being a
landlord
money talks it's just the way the way in
the world and so the result of this
is that he ends up giving her the room
right letting her letting her rent the
room and while all that's going on you
have her being washed by clown hunter
who is essentially preparing to blow the
whole place up now here's the funny
thing about it the guy's watching videos
about how to make his own homemade
rocket launcher right he's like thanks
mr internet
i sure am ready to create my own rocket
launcher and fire it into a person's
home
that's that's a little that's a little
extreme but he's literally learning from
the internet the problem with this is
that he's basically met by the arrival
of
ghost maker and ghost maker is like
we're going to kill this kid
right off the bat and that's kind of the
crazy thing is that like when this kid's
talking to him he's like you know i'm
not really sure that i like you you know
and he's like well you know
i'm sure that's a good thing right like
you really shouldn't like me because in
a minute i'm gonna kill you but like you
know here in gotham city
batman is in the business of like taking
criminals and putting them in jail and
hoping they stay there
and then like you know when they get out
rounding them back up again the batman
looks around and says it's not my job to
keep them
keep them in jail that's the criminal
justice system's job and yes the
criminal justice system is flawed but
like it's their job to fix it right i'm
just basically the dog catcher it's not
my place to change
things it's just my place to enforce
things right but like at the end of the
day it's kind of like this guy's lazy
right he's just a lazy superhero is all
it is right i mean if you have the
ability to change things then it's your
job to change things
and if the criminal justice system
doesn't work well then as you're as a
self-appointed
superhero in gotham because remember
it's not as though gotham appointed
batman
batman chose that he's like i am going
to protect gotham city and then i'm
going to define how it is that i do it
on my own
based on this super screwed up and
flawed justice system it's one of these
things where he kind of calls into the
whole nature of bruce right now of
course that leads to batman jumping in
right and immediately attacking ghost
maker and just being like okay
like we had an agreement this is my city
and the responsive ghost maker is
then do your job and that's the crazy
thing here because he's like this whole
city is rotting from the inside out it's
rotting from the poor and the destitute
who stay poor
and who stay living in destitution it's
rotting from the wealthy who capitalize
on them
and keep them there it's rotting from
like the criminals that keep escaping
from jail and that you keep rounding up
and putting it back
instead of instead of looking at them
and saying they're incorrigible human
beings that the joker will always kill
people and because of the nature of the
joker and the nature of these criminals
the justice system
just can't hold them right the jails
just can't hold these guys and so
because jails can't hold them and
because they keep getting out and
because they keep killing people that in
your desire to believe the justice
system can hold them you're sacrificing
innocent lives you're getting people
killed if you were any measure of a man
who could do what needed to be done
you would have killed them a long time
ago you know and that's that's the crazy
thing is this guy ghost maker
is not really a villain and i like that
philosophy right i like i'd like a
unlike a character that will look at
batman and say you're you're sacrificing
innocent people's lives because you
believe that it's wrong to kill but if
you believe it's wrong to kill then
what's worse here who's worse in this
situation
the person who kills a hundred people or
the person who could have stopped them
and didn't which one of these two people
is worse in this circumstance and that's
what's so wild about that is it creates
like these super philosophical
discussions right these super
philosophical debates over over who
really is at fault here if batman could
kill the joker and he knows joker's
gonna kill a whole bunch of people isn't
batman at fault here for not
killing him isn't that a legitimate case
to make there i think it is
and so because of that these two guys
start going at each other and initially
batman kind of takes this idea of okay
fine then like let's fight this out and
initially it's like you know we're doing
this to save clown hunter but the
responsive ghost maker is no no you and
i
we're not gonna play this game like
we're not gonna fight each other you
know for the sake of like
clown hunter we're gonna fight each
other for gotham city if i defeat you
i'm going to kill you and when i do i'm
going to take over gotham city that's
the craziest thing about this
is like this guy's kind of legit and i
agree with his philosophies like i
like ghost maker but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob corp if you guys
enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you